donc je vais faire la visite du décor
des mille et une nuits ici à la scène
nationale de château
voilà et ballon si une fille mais le
fammac à 10,6 me guillaume vincent
metteur en scène de la pièce les mille
et une nuits créé à paris au théâtre de
l'odéon à la rencontre du public à celle
roussat s'est inspiré du du décor de la
mosquée de paris en fait est de fort
inhabituelle façon puisqu'il conduit le
groupe à la découverte de l'envers du
décor majestueux ingénieux et techniques
du spectacle qui participe grandement à
la réussite de celui ci après aussi cet
escalier il s'en va voyez taxer de
manière assez rapide
on enlève l'escalier pour pouvoir ranger
aussi c'est l'un des avantages d'une
scène nationale son statut lui confère
des missions particulières échanger avec
des créateurs des artistes en fait
partie et le célèbre metteur en scène
n'hésite pas à jouer le jeu en révélant
toute la technique qui permet aux décors
de se mettre au service du propos de la
pièce avec brio ouvre en silence voilà
là il ya la petite marque pour dire aux
techniciens c'est là que ça doit passer
par est de retour au café qu'ils
n'optent autour d'un plat ou d'une
boisson
la structure est gérée par une
association et permet ces temps
d'échangés de rencontres dans un lieu
amicale autour d'un spectacle c'est une
des facettes de l'action culturelle
menée par la structure envers ces
publics
l'idée c'est que l'art la
sensibilisation à l'art et puis là et la
culture le fait de partager la culture
de fer culture ensemble c'est ça n'est
pas que le moment du spectacle ou du
film parce que au sein de
l'internationale également un cinéma
c'est aussi tout ce qui peut se passer
autour il existe 74 scène nationale
labellisé par le ministère de la culture
pour mener à bien les missions qui leur
sont confiées
elle dispose d'un budget abondé par
plusieurs sources
celui de châteauroux et de 3 millions 3